SPEAKER_00: Good afternoon, Robert. Thanks for coming in to discuss estate planning.
SPEAKER_01: Well, I figured it was time. I'm fifty-five now, kids are-- kids are grown up.
SPEAKER_00: Smart timing. A lot of people put this off until it's too late. So, um, tell me about your current situation - family, assets, that sort of thing.
SPEAKER_01: Married to Linda for twenty-eight years. Two kids - David's twenty-six, Sarah's twenty-four. Both doing well, thankfully.
SPEAKER_00: Good. And asset-wise? I know from our previous meetings you've built up a decent portfolio, but let's go through the details.
SPEAKER_01: Well, the house is worth about nine hundred thousand now. No mortgage left. RRSPs total around four hundred thousand.
SPEAKER_00: That's between you and Linda combined?
SPEAKER_01: No, that's just mine. Linda has about two hundred thousand in hers.
SPEAKER_00: Okay, so six hundred total in RRSPs. What about TFSAs?
SPEAKER_01: We've both maxed those out. About ninety thousand each, so one-eighty total.
SPEAKER_00: Non-registered investments?
SPEAKER_01: Maybe three hundred thousand in my taxable account. Mix of stocks and bonds.
SPEAKER_00: So we're looking at roughly... what... one point four million in total assets?
SPEAKER_01: Sounds about right. Plus I've got a small pension from my previous employer.
SPEAKER_00: What's that worth? And are you still working now?
SPEAKER_01: The pension's maybe fifty thousand in present value. And yeah, I'm still working. Making about a hundred and thirty thousand.
SPEAKER_00: Excellent. So you're in a good position. Now, estate planning in Canada has some... some unique considerations. The biggest one is the deemed disposition rule.
SPEAKER_01: Deemed disposition?
SPEAKER_00: When you die, Canada treats it as if you sold all your assets at fair market value. So any capital gains get triggered immediately. Could create a significant tax bill for your estate.
SPEAKER_01: Even if I don't actually sell anything?
SPEAKER_00: Right. It's a fiction, but the tax is real. On your non-registered investments, any appreciation since you bought them becomes taxable.
SPEAKER_01: What kind of tax bill are we talking about?
SPEAKER_00: Hard to say without knowing your cost basis, but... let's say you have a hundred thousand in capital gains. That's fifty thousand in taxable capital gains at your marginal rate. Maybe twenty-five thousand in tax?
SPEAKER_01: That's a lot of money.
SPEAKER_00: It can be. And that's just the non-registered stuff. RRSPs are even worse - the full balance becomes taxable income in your final year.
SPEAKER_01: The full four hundred thousand?
SPEAKER_00: If it goes to your kids directly, yes. That would push your final tax return into the highest bracket. We're talking close to two hundred thousand in taxes.
SPEAKER_01: Jesus. Half the RRSP gone to taxes?
SPEAKER_00: At current rates, yeah. Though there are ways too minimize this. If Linda inherits your RRSP, she can roll it into her own tax-free. That defers the tax bill.
SPEAKER_01: But then Linda faces the same problem when she dies?
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. So we need strategies to get money out of RRSPs gradually while you're both alive. What are you planning for retirement age?
SPEAKER_01: Maybe sixty-two? I could afford to retire then.
SPEAKER_00: Good. That gives us seven years to start drawing down RRSPs strategically. Even if you don't need the money, you might want too convert some to TFSAs or non-registered accounts.
SPEAKER_01: Convert RRSPs to TFSAs?
SPEAKER_00: Well, you'd withdraw from the RRSP, pay tax on it, then contribute the after-tax amount to your TFSA if you have room. Future growth would then be tax-free.
SPEAKER_01: Do we have TFSA room left?
SPEAKER_00: You're both maxed now, but you get new room each year. In twenty twenty-four it's... um... seven thousand each. So fourteen thousand annually you could shelter from future taxes.
SPEAKER_01: That seems small compared to the RRSP balances.
SPEAKER_00: It is, but every bit helps. And there are other strategies. What about life insurance?
SPEAKER_01: I have some group coverage through work.
SPEAKER_00: How much? And does it continue into retirement?
SPEAKER_01: Two hundred thousand, and no, it ends when I retire.
SPEAKER_00: So there's a potential gap. Life insurance can be a good estate planning tool because the death benefit is generally tax-free to beneficiaries.
SPEAKER_01: But I'd have to pay premiums for years.
SPEAKER_00: True. It's really about liquidity. If your estate faces a big tax bill, insurance provides cash to pay it without having to sell other assets.
SPEAKER_01: What would that cost at my age?
SPEAKER_00: Depends on your health and the amount. Term insurance might be fifteen hundred annually for too hundred thousand coverage. Permanent insurance would be much more.
SPEAKER_01: Term insurance ends eventually though, right?
SPEAKER_00: Usually at age seventy or eighty. The idea is that by then you've hopefully reduced your estate tax exposure through other strategies.
SPEAKER_01: What other strategies?
SPEAKER_00: Well, gifting during your lifetime is one. If you give assets to your kids now, the capital gains get triggered, but you can plan the timing to minimize tax.
SPEAKER_01: So I'd pay tax on the gains now instead of later?
SPEAKER_00: Right. And if you're in a lower tax bracket now than your estate would be, that could save money overall.
SPEAKER_01: Are there limits on gifting to family?
SPEAKER_00: Not like in the US. Canada doesn't have gift taxes, but you still trigger capital gains when you transfer appreciated assets.
SPEAKER_01: What about the principal residence exemption?
SPEAKER_00: Your house should qualify. Only one principal residence per family, but the full gain is usually tax-free.
SPEAKER_01: Even nine hundred thousand worth?
SPEAKER_00: As long as it's been your principal residence the whole time you owned it. Though there are some rules about... let me think... about designating which property if you own multiple.
SPEAKER_01: We just have the one house.
SPEAKER_00: Then you should be fine. That's nine hundred thousand that transfers tax-free.
SPEAKER_01: What about trusts? I hear people talk about those.
SPEAKER_00: Trusts can be useful, but they're complex in Canada. We have attribution rules that can push income back to the person who funded the trust.
SPEAKER_01: So they don't save taxes?
SPEAKER_00: Not always. They're more about control and protection. Like if you're worried about a child going through a divorce or having creditor issues.
SPEAKER_01: My kids seem pretty stable, thankfully.
SPEAKER_00: That's good. Though you never know what the future holds. What are their financial situations like?
SPEAKER_01: David's an engineer, making good money. Sarah's a teacher, loves it but-- but not getting rich.
SPEAKER_00: So maybe different needs when it comes to inheritance timing?
SPEAKER_01: Possibly. Sarah could probably use help with a house down payment.
SPEAKER_00: That's where gifting during your lifetime makes sense. You can see the money being put too good use, and it starts reducing your estate tax exposure.
SPEAKER_01: How much can I give without triggering big tax bills?
SPEAKER_00: If it's cash from your savings, no immediate tax. If it's appreciated investments, you'd pay capital gains. But you could do it gradually over several years.
SPEAKER_01: What about RESPs? The kids are past that age.
SPEAKER_00: RESPs are great for grandchildren if that's ever relevant. The government grants make them very attractive while the kids are young.
SPEAKER_01: No grandkids yet, but maybe someday.
SPEAKER_00: Something to keep in mind. Now, let's talk about the mechanics. Do you have an up-to-date will?
SPEAKER_01: We did wills about ten years ago.
SPEAKER_00: Probably worth updating. Asset values have changed, maybe your wishes have too. What about powers of attorney?
SPEAKER_01: I think those are in the wills?
SPEAKER_00: Maybe, but they're usually separate documents. You want both financial and personal care powers of attorney in case you become incapacitated.
SPEAKER_01: Linda would handle that stuff.
SPEAKER_00: Right, but you want it documented properly. And what if you're both incapacitated? Maybe your kids as backup attorneys?
SPEAKER_01: That makes sense. What about executor duties?
SPEAKER_00: Being an executor in Canada is... it's a big job. Dealing with CRA, filing final tax returns, distributing assets. Takes months or years.
SPEAKER_01: Should I name both kids as co-executors?
SPEAKER_00: That can work, but sometimes creates conflict. One primary executor with the other as backup might be cleaner. Or even a professional trustee for complex estates.
SPEAKER_01: How complex is complex?
SPEAKER_00: Multiple properties, business interests, complicated family situations. Your estate is substantial but pretty straightforward.
SPEAKER_01: What about charitable giving?
SPEAKER_00: Great question. Charitable donations in your will get very generous tax credits - can often eliminate much of the final tax bill.
SPEAKER_01: How generous?
SPEAKER_00: You can claim up to one hundred percent of net income in the year of death, plus one hundred percent of the prior year. Credits are... um... roughly fifty percent at high income levels. Actually, let me double-check that calculation for you.
SPEAKER_01: So donate a hundred thousand, save fifty thousand in taxes?
SPEAKER_00: Roughly, yeah. It's actually more nuanced - the first two hundred dollars is fifteen percent federal credit, then twenty-nine percent, then there's provincial...
SPEAKER_01: Okay, but significant savings.
SPEAKER_00: Definitely. And if you're charitably inclined anyway, it's much more tax-efficient to give through your estate than during your lifetime.
SPEAKER_01: Why's that?
SPEAKER_00: During your lifetime, you're limited to seventy-five percent of net income for donations. At death, it's one hundred percent plus the carryback.
SPEAKER_01: Any charities you'd recommend?
SPEAKER_00: That's really personal. What causes matter to you and Linda? Education, health care, environment?
SPEAKER_01: We've always supported the local hospital.
SPEAKER_00: Perfect. You could leave them a specific bequest, or even a percentage of your estate. Just make sure they're a registered charity.
SPEAKER_01: How do I check that?
SPEAKER_00: CRA has a database of registered charities online. Pretty easy to search.
SPEAKER_01: What about taxes on Linda's death?
SPEAKER_00: Same issues, but potentially worse because she'd inherit your assets too. That's why it's important to start tax planning now.
SPEAKER_01: Should we be more aggressive about RRSP withdrawals?
SPEAKER_00: Maybe. If you can-- if you can withdraw at lower tax rates now versus higher rates later, it makes sense. What's your current marginal rate?
SPEAKER_01: About forty-three percent combined federal and provincial.
SPEAKER_00: So pretty high already. But in retirement it might be lower if your income drops significantly.
SPEAKER_01: What about pension splitting?
SPEAKER_00: Good point. Once you're sixty-five, you can split eligible pension income with Linda. Helps level out tax brackets.
SPEAKER_01: Eligible pension income?
SPEAKER_00: RRIF withdrawals, annuity payments, employer pension payments. But not RRSP withdrawals before they become RRIFs.
SPEAKER_01: When do RRSPs have to become RRIFs?
SPEAKER_00: End of the year you turn seventy-one. Then you're forced to take minimum withdrawals annually.
SPEAKER_01: How much are the minimums?
SPEAKER_00: Starts around five percent at seventy-two, increases each year. By age ninety it's over ten percent. Can create big tax bills.
SPEAKER_01: So better to start withdrawals earlier voluntarily?
SPEAKER_00: Often, yes. Gives you more control over the timing and amounts. Plus you can reinvest the after-tax money in TFSAs or non-registered accounts.
SPEAKER_01: This is getting complicated. Should we work with an estate lawyer?
SPEAKER_00: For updating your wills and powers of attorney, absolutely. They'll make sure everything's properly documented and legally valid.
SPEAKER_01: Any other professionals we should involve?
SPEAKER_00: Maybe an accountant who specializes in estate tax planning. They can model different scenarios and help optimize the timing of withdrawals.
SPEAKER_01: And you'll coordinate with them?
SPEAKER_00: Of course. Estate planning works best when everyone's on the same page - lawyer, accountant, financial advisor.
SPEAKER_01: What's our next step?
SPEAKER_00: I'd suggest we run some projections on different withdrawal strategies from your RRSPs. Then you can make informed decisions about timing.
SPEAKER_01: And get those wills updated.
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. Ten years is a long time. Your asset values have grown significantly, and the tax implications have changed too.
SPEAKER_01: Thanks for explaining all this. It's a lot too digest.
SPEAKER_00: Estate planning isn't glamorous, but it's one of the most important things you can do for your family. Better to plan now while you have options.
SPEAKER_01: I'll talk to Linda about all this tonight.
SPEAKER_00: Good. And don't hesitate to call if you have questions as you think through everything.